now you may be wondering how many horror
stories
you have when you're an ra and i'm let
you know
the list is extensive
[Music]
hey my name is eric i was in r.a for a
year in college
hey i'm laura and i was an r.a for three
years in college
hi everybody my name is angel and i was
an r.a for three years in college and
today we're going to be sharing our
horror stories
what was that
i remember about eight years ago i was
the ra on duty
and it was really really wild because
usually things didn't happen
but this time i got a noise complaint
and noise complaints are really rare
when you're in ra
because i feel like everyone's being
noisy but on
this fateful evening i remember someone
called me and they were like yo the dorm
next to me is being super loud
you do something about it so i went over
and uh the music
was really loud i was like oh my lord
this is definitely a little louder than
usual
and i knocked on the door no one
answered but
people were definitely in there i knock
again knock knock knock
no one's answering still loud music they
probably can't hear me so
what we do is we have like a super
skeleton key that unlocks
every dorm ooh the power of being an ra
so i open the door
and i walk in to an orgy there were
probably about
seven people eight people you know what
i didn't really
count because there were other things
that i was like whoa look at that look
at that oh my god look at that
it was so crazy because when i walked in
the door it was like a needle scratched
because
everyone looked at me i looked at
everyone
and i was just like you guys need to
keep the noise down
and i just slowly closed the door locked
it
and then went about my way i didn't
really know what to do didn't report it
to my boss
but i guess the lesson of the story is
if you are throwing an
orgy in your dorm play better music
[Music]
so my horror story happened about eight
years ago i was a junior in college
and it was my second year as an r.a so i
felt like i got this in the bag
i had all girls again super ready for it
and i had one girl
who was on a full ride she was really
great honestly we got along super well
but as the semester was going on she
started gaining a lot of weight
and as an r.a you kind of think okay
maybe that's related to depression so
we're trained to just kind of check in
on that
so i checked in with her and i was like
how are things going and she just said
oh like everything's really
really good i'm getting straight a's in
my classes i'm doing really well with my
newish boyfriend it's all good i'm like
great
not over by thanksgiving this girl my
resident tells me
hey i'm pregnant what wow that's a lot
okay you're on full scholarship let's
let's figure out how to keep you going
i knew that this baby was gonna come
next semester
so spring break happens we come back
boom
baby baby
was now living on our floor
in a dorm not as a college student as a
newborn baby
what after about a week of this baby
being one of my residents essentially i
went down to my resident director and i
was like
look this is not okay so my boss goes
okay
i believe you let's write a report and
i'm gonna send it to
the head of resident directing and
instead of kicking her
out of school which is not what we
wanted they did decide to put her in
off-campus housing that was safe
where she could still keep her
scholarship and have this child
she got through pregnancy birth and
freshman year with a smile on her face
and straight a's
like if this girl can do that we can all
get through college
so my most traumatic horror story is
when i was an
r.a my junior year i'm with the other
ras and we're like you know chit-chat
and talking
and then all of a sudden this girl who's
like five feet nothing
she burst into the lounge and she's just
like
oh my gosh oh my gosh she's
panting and like she's out of breath
she's breathing like oxygen is going out
of style and i was like
oh she's in danger like somebody's after
her somebody's trying to get her
so i'm i'm a little freaked out and she
looks at me
and like dead in my face she's like
there's a volcano
of sh coming out of my toilet and i was
like
there's a what and she's just like
there's a volcano
of sh okay something's not right here
i'm gonna need you to take me to the
problem because
at this point i just don't believe her
so she takes me through the
little apartment complex and i can
already smell
human ways all of a sudden i can
literally see
in her like apartment hallway gross
water on the floor
she really didn't lie to me um
i don't have training for this unless
y'all know i don't have training for
this
they sure don't pay us enough for me to
deal with human waste in any way shape
or form
i literally walked out of the apartment
i was like i've seen enough i called the
department of public safety i was like
hello eventually a maintenance man comes
it took him like an hour apparently
and so i go to follow up with the
resident
and she's just like oh my gosh thank you
so much for helping me
she's just like yeah she's like so have
a good night and i'm like
wait i was like do you not want me to
put you in contact with like one of my
supervisors or something like that
like you know she was like no uh no
thanks
and she left and i never saw her again
so
i don't know what happened to that girl
but very low maintenance resident
i guess the moral of the story here is
when you're an array
you see some and sometimes it's a lot
[Music]
you